en nouvelle zélande le pays entier est
sous confinement sévère depuis à peine
deux semaines mais déjà les mesures
semblent porter fruit
ces deux derniers jours le nombre de
nouveaux cas a diminué et ce malgré une
augmentation importante du nombre de
tests effectués le caractère insulaire
du pays et l'éloignement de l'archipel
ont assurément un effet sur le faible
nombre de cas la fermeture des
frontières est plus facile à assurer qu
en europe par exemple le confinement est
stricte en plus des commerces jugés non
essentiels
tous les parcs les plages les lieux
publics sont interdits des mesures
respecté par la majorité de la
population
la majorité met tous les membres du
gouvernement n'ont pas donné l'exemple
le ministre de la santé lui même a violé
deux fois les règles du confinement pour
pratiquer des activités extérieures loin
de son domicile
étant donné les circonstances de la
pandémie
il n'a pas été limogé par la première
ministre mais a tout de même reçu un
blâme et et délester de certaines
fonctions on compte actuellement un peu
plus de 1000 cas en nouvelle-zélande
dont un seul décès et avec à peine 2 %
de contamination liée à une transmission
communautaire
les autorités se félicitent d'avoir
serré autant la vis
le confinement doit se poursuivre pour
encore 14 jours soit le temps d'un autre
cycle d'incubation
mais la première ministre a octroyé une
permission spéciale
aujourd'hui on y dénombre 54 nouveaux
cas mais 65 personnes guéries dans le
bilan quotidien
un revirement dans les statistiques que
les autorités espèrent voir se
transformer en une tendance durable ici
julier mon radio canada montréal